hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i am ridiculously excited
to be here virtually with heather mann
and heather mann is an amazing
person she is a self-made millionaire so
always good to
be on the call with um self-made
millionaires and she became a self-made
millionaire by age
25 which is just incredible
um absolute expert the queen of
trading uh she's also done property
she's runs the fortune academy
massive massive heart loves to give back
and teach people
you see here's the thing most rich
people hide away so it's great to see
when people
share and teach what they do so publicly
and openly so hither
great to have you on the court how are
you doing thank you
samuel that is such an exciting like
intro so i appreciate your energy you're
great honestly um
i'm honored to be here and i love what
you do and i like your story so it's
really
quite fun to have this conversation and
um you know see what value i can bring
to your amazing audience that you have
that's great so listen i mean my
audience tend to be around the same kind
of age as me
so i'm 29 so i get a lot of people who
are kind of like 25
30 years old watching watching my
channel the fact that you became
a multi-millionaire by age 25 um
is is is incredible so just just just on
that note alone but i know you've gone
on
to do crazy other things since then um
tell me a little bit about your
background because i know you were not
born with a silver spoon in your mouth
so
talk to me a little bit about your
background and then i want to unravel
how you became
so successful at such a young age thank
you um yeah so my background similar to
yourself i guess was um
no money in the family in fact i
remember at the age of nine
i grew up in kenya by the way and then i
moved my family emigrated
um to immigrated to england so
pretty much immigrant kind of story and
it was very similar
um childhood for many people that i've
come across who
grew up with no money it can go two ways
either you just think yeah
money is horrible and i never want it or
it goes the other way and you get
obsessed with i need to make money
because i'm going to fix these problems
my parents are arguing about
so i grew up with a lot of um family
arguments
parents just at each other because they
were just unhappy and i wanted to just
make things
better i guess as a young person a bit
naive obviously i just thought money is
everything
of course it's not but it definitely
helps
bring in more options and i just became
my whole focus in life became right
let's uh do whatever it takes to make
money and be super wealthy i didn't know
how
i was just going to be wealthy i knew
that for sure yeah so
so right from a younger age you had this
desire to want to make money you didn't
you start didn't you start your first
business at nine
no well at nine years old i was i was
actually an academic
um i don't think i actually had an
official business as such but
i i grew up my dad was the kind of guy
that said if you want to be wealthy
because
he was just a traditional thinking guy
and he said you just need to be into
education like you need to ace your
grades and
i never realized education was i wasn't
into it i was
became an academic because i thought
that was how you make money
but then i realized okay none of this
stuff is actually teaching me how to
make
proper money i got a career university
whatever
but it wasn't the millionaire life until
i started
property at um in 2004 onwards that's
when things started changing
so you're feeling the thing is that uh
most most traditional education
will teach you how to get a job yeah 100
i got exactly that type of thing so i i
think education education is great don't
i'm not telling anyone
never to do education i was doing i went
into the medical field so obviously we
need doctors opticians sponsors whatever
and that was one of that was me
so i was an optician and obviously you
need education for that
but if you had a burning ambition to be
like this business person
to have lots of money it's not going to
come from a
traditional field like that not fast
anyway
i mean not by the age of 25 i don't know
many multi-millionaire
uh medics doctors i mean yeah it's not
it's not
heard of whereas business people i feel
if i started
business at the age of 16 i wish i knew
nothing and that's
why i love education uh you know
providers like yourself and that's why i
create fortune academy because if i
heard stuff like that at a younger age
i would have probably taken proxy more
seriously younger i would have started
doing financial training i would have
done stuff that
i could have that i knew nothing about
till my 20s you know so
yeah interesting as well the property
was your first sort of proper business
where you started making money
and then you transitioned into trading
which we'll get on to and i'm really
interested in
um you know unraveling that and finding
out more about that and how that works
um what when was the first time that you
really started making money as an
entrepreneur because you went down the
traditional education route
um but when did you first sort of think
man i'm i'm making money in property or
as an entrepreneur when did that kind of
happen
uh i i think the big money at about 21
onwards
because that's when i started looking at
properties and got into property
networking groups i think i'm quite late
you know honestly i come across young
people and they're amazing
i mean you probably started younger but
i don't think i particularly started
that young but i think in a three-year
period you can turn your life around
massively if you're 100
focused and that was me um i started
earning money for my i started paying
for bills in the family household from
16 so i had like
really good jobs and stuff i used to
have like a 14 year old person's job
and that 9 to 5 ethic actually taught me
okay this stuff i don't want to have a 9
to 5.
uh so me working really hard i had no
school holidays i had none of that
so a lot of young millennials as we know
are i feel a little lazy like they just
kind of
feel like everything should be just easy
on their fingertips with something
online
and they don't have that hard work ethic
and i used to get out there
no school holidays never went on any
kind of i never had
going to friends houses and stuff like
that i was a bit of a
recluse but i made money and that was
from as young as i could
uh legally start you know getting an
income in the uk
so that was my story but i started
making big money when i started going to
property networking groups brought you
know
brand new concept to me never knew
anything about it
i met people when i was 21 22 i started
meeting people that were 40 plus
not many people your age were there i'll
be honest it was probably a handful of
like young 20 year olds
uh but most of them were much older and
that's the kind of people i learned from
so that was
that was good and that's what i feel is
so needed in this world now we need more
people who constantly share
knowledge about how to make money for
young people because i just feel like
they i didn't have that
i was going to ask you what year that
was but then i then i think that would
be a rude question because i'm trying to
i'm okay i'm open with age uh i'm 38 now
so much older than you nearly 10 years
older
um i was born in 1982 so 2004
is when i started buying my first
properties i bought three in one go
um as you do but it was it was that was
a turning point for me so
that before that 2003 started delving
into property networking groups
2004 made my first transaction never
looked back you know and it was
great amazing let me talk about that
because when i was 21
i was also networking rooms i was going
to all these different types of meetings
and events actually
before i was 21 i was i was actually
super young um
i think you're right it wasn't cool like
now i feel like being an entrepreneur is
kind of cool
now i see like a lot of 19 20 year olds
going to networking events or at least
talking about it on social media
when i started it wasn't cool i could
only imagine how much uncooler it was
when you started i didn't know you were
30 yeah you looked like my edge i was
thinking you probably got 59.
so like make up those thank you very
much
back in those days i don't know maybe
you're probably talking about what 2004
or something
yeah 2003 2004 when i started i knew
nothing about these kind of amazing
networking groups
yeah it was like an all boys club
honestly and i've been used to being in
the uh i've always been in a male
industry and that's why as a female now
i want to encourage more female
entrepreneurs i want to encourage
well anyone young really but i was fully
not like fitting in because i was the
youngest person stuck out like a sore
thumb
and a female and 99 of that room was
male
uh maybe one or two dotted wives but
that was it you know so it's um
i wasn't intimidated because i was i was
just naturally like that but i feel like
that's
i'm so glad now entrepreneurialism is so
much cooler and you're very very right
in saying that because it is
um and people like you are helping
others young
like your age and younger to to find
that kind of excitement about it and and
people
like you i mean as a woman as well it's
great to see
successful women that have done very
very well
not only not hiding away but the
opposite i see you putting yourself out
there continually on social media
inspiring men and women of a lot of
different ages
but i think it's i think it's a really
admirable thing to do
i mean when you got started did you have
funds from somewhere did you use savings
how did you get started at such a young
age
okay so a quick answer no one gave me
money
except when i started networking i
started learning that you can get
bridging finance that you can get other
people's money too
so when i started um i was earning
through the optician job so i was making
about 9k a month
working seven days a week like
commission sales whatever
i was a good closer and that's something
i learned when i was 16 so i feel like
if anyone wants to do property and do
well
you need to be a good closer because
you're negotiating with
you know uh vendors of a property i was
doing this typical bnb thing so my first
knowledge into property it was quite
interesting because i knew none of this
normal stuff i went straight into bmv's
the only way you should buy
and that really helped me because i was
like below market value if anyone i'm
sure you got your audience knows
but um yeah so i always bought cheap
properties i never bought market value
if i ever went into an estate agent i'll
be hanging out with the
uh the less the actual agents not the
owner because i know the owner is never
going to give me stuff but i would make
friends with the guys that are getting
paid on commission and pay them the
commission for full price but give them
get me the lower price so i was very
good at negotiating a deal
so simply when it came to it my earnings
pay for conveyancing fees that was it
and
i got everything done through um
back-to-back
so at the time you could do bridging and
mortgage express back-to-back so
we know those days that's how i that was
and i started that was just
that was i came right at the very tail
end of that oh
wow did you enjoy any of that because
that was
i did one house i got one i got i got
one house which was which was um five
refinance same day
mortgage and then boom they changed the
rules
i can see how you starting quite a few
years before that
with the mindset that you've got and the
drive that you've got
using that creative strategy i can see
how you killed it in 2004-2004
100 i mean you to do something like that
i thought
kind of easy because i loved it you know
like i thought oh my god where else can
you make 30k on
one deal per property and that's pure
tax-free cash because it was a debt from
a mortgage but you had
cash flow so it was so it was amazing
the tax man couldn't touch your your
earnings
um it was all above board it was amazing
um
but one thing that was difficult and i
feel that most people when i ever talk
to them casually about okay this is how
you buy cheap properties
they can't understand how much marketing
is involved like i had
paper leaflets from i had a team doing
paper leaflet drops and
it's not easy to do that you to find
this
find the deal that's the hard bit the
negotiation is
yeah you've got to have a personality
that can close so i guess there was a
lot of skill set but i found it because
i started in sales at 16
uh by the age of 22 i was pretty good
you know so i'm like you've dealt with a
rejection you've dealt with the hey
you've dealt with
um people not liking you um and i feel
like
another piece of advice for your
audience if they are young
one challenge i massively had was that
men
many people didn't take me seriously as
a vet like if i was going into a bengals
house
they never thought she can buy my house
like how the hell does that work like
she's like
half my age some of them hate that
sometimes i had to pretend oh yeah i'm
using my dad's money or
this is my dad's house i'm collecting
the rent like they wouldn't take me
seriously
and it was quite annoying yeah oh is
that because you're younger because
you're a woman or both
i i'd say both definitely female because
there's not many of them
um of doing that at that time i'm sure
now it's changing massively
uh and i like that but because they're
changing massively because you're
inspiring people to do different things
so
yeah yeah obviously i'll say that not
not lightly because
i really believe that there's not that
many people killing it
in business and showing stuff out there
and showing other people the way there's
not that many people and those few
people that are doing that
like gary vaynerchuk has single-handedly
changed the way people people do
business
so respect gary vaynerchuk yeah i'm
changing the way people do property
you're changing the way people people
see the um the financial market and
forex and trading
so no i i don't mean to kind of like
um you know sound like i'm being
arrogant or anything like that but and i
know that we also
people like us that put our heads above
the parapet we do it we do upset people
you know we do get people saying
you know oh it's and people say this
about you i've seen she got lucky
because in in 2004
you the mortgage express and this
everybody's like hold on a minute here
the man
got lucky in property then she got lucky
in forex then she got lucky by having a
really successful training company
how many times can you keep getting
lucky it's not about getting lucky it's
about looking behind the head right now
and seeing what we both got behind us
we've got loads of books
yeah yeah absolutely i didn't i didn't
i didn't intend on being in this room i
was supposed to enough room and then i
moved because my computer would be funny
but
i'm i'm continually learning educating
myself
what about you talk to me about some of
the people um that maybe inspired you
the authors the trainers i'm sure i just
it goes about saying that you have had a
lot of mentors and you've spent a lot of
money in that
oh yeah 100 i i that's why i love doing
what i do at fortune academy because i
felt like i wanted to be the change
that instead of complaining about oh
there's not enough women there's not
enough
young people especially for me i guess
i'm a mini feminist i feel like i have
to pretend
i can't pretend i'm not basically i have
loads of guys like my
audience is um 70 male as in my students
uh my traders my business clients but i
am getting more and more women um so
what it comes down to is yeah mental so
in the in terms of books funny enough
when it came to property
i read every single one of donald
trump's books i still got them there at
the back
the guy who was a legend when it came to
closing a deal and like dealing with
hate
is the first time i saw in a book that
he was open about
the amount of hate he got and he said if
i'm not getting sued every month every
week
then there's something wrong like i had
never read that in a book
that it was okay to get that kind of
hate and be like
f i don't give a damn you know so i
found that a little bit like wow that's
pretty cool uh
you know whatever so it was a first
little bit of insight for
um me to understand that hate does come
with
success i never had that much at the
beginning as you normally do but
you do get a lot of problems coming up
in the future when people just don't
like you being rich and
they they want to try and get in your
way or sabotage something uh but in
terms of other authors
i did the normal stuff like robert
kiyosaki in terms of the actual physical
mentals i had
i actually learned a lot from palm
deepadesha who's actually gone quite
quiet now so he was a guy who taught me
all the bmv stuff
um there was people like hanif there's
uh another guy called vanish
there there are people from london but i
went to the london property networking
groups
i went to berkshire property networking
groups and birmingham all the pin stuff
before some of the big players came out
now i guess we all started at the same
time
um you know i feel like there's all
these guys you're talking about i know
these guys i remember
amazing amazing
why did you then go into because this is
this is kind of why i wanted you on the
show
why did you then go from property which
you did very very well
making good money from it to then um you
went into trading
talk to me about trading and talked to
me about the pros and cons property
we can even argue about this yeah yeah i
love this conversation honestly i
love it because i have all my property
portfolio they pay me amazing passive
income every month like it's great
but the turning point came from this so
i'm gonna go back to 2008 when the crash
happened to be honest by this point in
my life
i was working 18 hours a day because
even though i had money
it doesn't mean i just got lazy i
actually was constantly i was picking up
rent in cash at 11 o'clock at night like
that was the kind of person i was i was
hustling all the time i loved it like i
just enjoyed the
the game i guess and i bought a lot of
my property in an area that i was living
around so
it wasn't as scattered as i have got
more now in places i've never been to
but at that time i was quite traditional
two postcodes i went crazy you know i
was like i knew the area i knew
everyone knew me um and i knew what
properties i wanted to buy so
i was burnt out i'll be very honest i
got to a point where
tenants started taking the piss a little
bit so this is a problem i had i didn't
do much for
a commercial maybe that was a mistake i
did more residential
in fact most of my properties are still
residential now and um
so what i was finding is that i was
doing hmos most
of them were hmos students of
universities
they were high maintenance like there
would be a woman
caught and i used to manage myself so if
you imagine your phone ringing oh
there's ants in the house like
piss off like sometimes i would get
angry and be like i'm not your mom like
fix it so i used to get a little bit
pissed off with
well i'm not a little bit massively
pissed off and i used to find myself
getting really angry really quick
and i was getting burnt out unhappy had
a really [ __ ] relationship
so my life was pretty much going down so
i had lots of money
but i didn't have enough headspace to
clear my actual mind
as well um so what actually happened in
2008 i felt like it was a blessing in
disguise
i would never have stopped i would never
have stopped trade um
property or hustling the way i did the
fact that market crashed and there were
no more mortgages coming and mortgage
express
stopped and everything else just became
like no for eight months i was just
doing
nothing enjoying life you know and then
i walked into my office one day
and it was just me my mortgage broker
that were in the office two-man team you
know the rest was
uh outsourced and um at that time
he was on a laptop because can you
imagine a mortgage broker they're
struggling they're not making any money
on mortgages
i'm not i was his major client so at
this point
he had found something new and he
started playing on this chat thing i'd
never seen a financial chat in my life
i had no interest in bloomberg i hated
politics which i still do
i didn't like economy i thought these
people have pulled the hell at me
but he was on a chart and he was i said
what are you doing like he was all
dressed up i was like why are you
dressed up no one's
talking to you so um and he was making
i said so he said this is the world of
forex i was like okay i kind of think i
know what i'm talking you're talking
about
he said currency markets i was like sure
tell me the good stuff how much money
you're making
and at the time half past 10 in the
morning he was making 880 pounds
from a 10 grand account and i was like
that looks easy you know like you're
just sitting there
you're not speaking to anyone so for me
the very naive thinking was
okay you don't have to speak to anyone
in the world i could be anywhere
and i can make money from my laptop i'm
in you know and that was what made me
feel like
wow i can actually work on me i went on
13 holidays
it did it wasn't a simple case of me
just learning it and instantly making
money i lost a lot of money before i got
proper mentor
but um the whole obsession with time
buying back my time was everything i
wanted because i was stuck
in in an area called coventry which i'm
sure you know of
i know very well okay fine so carpentry
was
where i've got a lot of my houses and i
love that place for the whole
entrepreneurial spirit like there's a
lot of
big money thinking people there i feel
like you can make money there because
it's
cheap houses good yields amazing you
know so um
i never left that place for ages for
almost seven years of my life i can't
remember okay so by this point i was at
least
2008 i think 27 26 27
i was i didn't go on a proper holiday so
i was like okay i've got all this money
i'm in a [ __ ] relationship i feel [ __ ]
uh and i've never seen the world
what am i doing with my life you know i
was kind of like a midlife crisis
accelerated
um so yeah financial trading gave me
that space
eventually when i started making the
money i made let's say
nine grand a month was what i was making
as a optician
seven times seven times a week uh
working some days
i made 9k in two hours on trading that
was a shift in my head i was thinking
how the hell do i i used to think money
was
something you've got to exchange a lot
of time for now i've just made
it casually sitting in a in a coffee
club in my sports center like in my um
tennis club type thing and i've just
made it in the morning and i'm thinking
[ __ ] this is stuff that i wish i knew
earlier
so that was what made me obsessed with
it i opened my eyes to the whole world
my property business then i outsourced
i've
got people to manage it i wouldn't have
had that if i didn't know something else
existed which is why i love it so much
i don't know which one i do first i'll
be honest uh i think
property taught me a lot but yeah give
me the argument i mean i'll probably
to be honest i mean i wouldn't really
argue with anything you've said i mean
my
my philosophy is do what you know
and i think you're successful not
because you hit looking with forex or
with property listen you could do
anything and you'd be
you could set up a hairdressing salon
and you'd kill it and become a
millionaire
yeah so so from my perspective
i think that i love property okay i i
i'm
obsessed with property but property is a
vehicle to achieve financial freedom
and i would be naive to say that there's
not other vehicles that can do that too
so
you know business and trading and um
you know for again i don't know um
amazon drop shipping i don't really know
that much
about it but i can't deny that yeah sure
it's a thing people are doing it people
are making money at it i've got friends
that are doing it so
whilst this is a property channel
primarily and i know you started out
made a lot of money in property
i think my audience you know i do get
people asking me about things like forex
and
people dabbling so i guess i really just
wanted to get you on to talk a little
bit about
what the heck it is and how it works and
how
to go about making money in trading so
firstly
what is forex like how how is it even
what is it what does it mean so such an
indie
simple industry right the industry is
something we've all been in so for
example when you go on holiday you're
using one currency when you're at home
and then you go to another one you
automatically
if you use the same bank card your bank
is transferring the currency for you
if you take cash out and then you change
it in the old-fashioned way you go to a
you know uh exchange desk you get cash
for another currency
now let's imagine you had a thousand
pound you're uh
sterling you go to somewhere like new
york you convert it
before you go to to uh dollars right um
let's for argument's sake let's say you
get like twelve hundred
dollars then you don't use the cash
because it was like the emergency fund
then you used your card everywhere and
then you come back and you're like okay
same cash point
same same exchange person let me change
it back to my pound sterling
do we get the same money back no because
the point is either is
you can get more back if the currency is
in your favor
or you can get less uh because it's
changed against you
plus there's a bit of commission gone to
the person that's exchanging the money
so that's the industry in a nutshell
it's
literally one currency versus another
you can make money whether it's going up
down
recession proof like i learned forex in
the last recession 2008
now we can argue that 2020 is going to
be like tipping point for the next one i
feel like we're
i'm very excited like this is my i
thrive in a recession period
because i feel there's more opportunity
so i i feel like
forex is the simplest industry in the
world to come to understand
the risk is people take the piss with it
like they literally just gamble
instead of thinking how should i trade
and that's why i love property people
when i ask
my traders when they come in have you
done property before if they say yes
i feel like they'll be a better trader
which is why i feel your audience
if they respect property the way you
teach them
um property is an asset like you know
you wouldn't just
flip it and next day you sell it you
know you you nurture it you kind of
create value and then
you you don't just abuse it you don't
gamble on bricks and mortar
if you have that same kind of attitude
with forex you make money
you really do it's the people that i
feel haven't got
done any property they're more likely to
take the piss a bit more
that's where i feel like the young
people really do take the piss
right when you don't take the piss you
just mean they don't get it they just
think it's just get rich quick
buttons on the screen i'm going to make
millions of pounds
no business is like that yeah and they
knowledge
and and persistence and the worst thing
i ever hear like
young people say and this is anyone 25
and under so maybe some of your audience
again
uh they try and make like 100 a month
and they try to start with a hundred
pound account and they like try and grow
this thing to
become monumental so the way i'm fixing
that problem is
okay start trying to get rich quick
second you need money just like in
property you need money but how did i do
well in property i use other people's
money so i'm telling them
i'll put the money in what's in it for
me will split the profits so that's
what's making me
really excited about teaching traders
because i'm getting them to become
an asset they're my assets i teach them
how to trade properly no get rich quick
thinking
and then if i feel like they're really
good and they've proven a track record
i'll put the money in we split the
profits and that's like another property
for me like they're creating rent for me
every month i've got like cash flow
so it's a simple model i've used my
property head
into fortune academy and put financial
trading
basically so basically you teach people
how to invest in forex
they then they then invest in forex they
get the skills and when they start
getting good at it you then sometimes
will give them your personal money
they'll invest your money they'll do all
the work and make it happen
and then you'll split the profits yes
yes it's very similar to property
in terms of that's kind of like what i
do oh
i teach people how to invest in property
i mean not not always last
last year 2019 i gave over a million
pounds of my own money to
to people to invest in property just
said i just want to slice the pie
and it's funny because sometimes people
say oh my gosh you know samuel's
teaching people
to train him to learn about property and
then he's making money off the back of
them by then and it's like hold on no no
i'm teaching them and then they're i'm
giving them money
and i'm taking that of course i'm
winning and that's okay but they're
winning too
everyone around me is winning i don't i
don't hang around losers everyone's
winning in my circles and i'm winning as
well
of course it's a joint venture is what
makes people know that you're invested
in their
in their training otherwise i'd just
teach them [ __ ] and be like yeah i'll
just charge you for the education and
then
see you later whereas i'm actually
wanting them to have
funds from me because the aim is that's
more valuable to me because they're
going to be a cash cow for me and that's
that's a model
obviously the people i'm saying no two
are the ones who have just got really
bad discipline there are
there's going to be a caveat that i say
no i'm not going to give you the money
because
if i feel they don't have the discipline
they don't follow rules they're just
going to burn my money so i wouldn't
want that to happen so
yeah very simple i feel like financial
trading is perfect for people who've
done property because they've got the
right thinking
investor mindset um i just feel like
it's it's easy for them
what would you say some of the biggest
um like successes in forex you've had
some some real wins some real like oh
yes some victories some or some just
some big achievements that you've had
that you're really proud of
so for financial training for me
personally like when i started making
like nine grand every two hours and i
think the first time i made 84 grand in
a week
i was like [ __ ] this is like stuff i was
excited about when i was young
about making a year or something you
know and i used to make that in a week
so i was very excited when i got those
kind of figures
after that i'd be honest the more money
you make i've become a lot safer
so what i've found myself doing before i
used to take a lot of risk
um and yeah you can make quite a lot of
money when you take a risk but you can
also lose
so i don't want to encourage people to
think everyone can make you know 84k a
week and stuff like that it depends how
much money you've got in there how much
risk so but it is possible
it is possible because we've got that
the most important thing is and i i
treat myself like a
uh a trading coach just like you would a
football coach um
my favorite football manager is that i
think you can see it just about alex
ferguson
yeah great guy like a legend for me like
i think the guy's a legend so
um and i always think if you've got to
invest in me
as a trader coach then see what i've
created as a result like that guy
created number seven shares
all the time and he created everything
like he any player that worked for them
was
usually pretty world class and i'm quite
proud to say that i've created that in
students so for example one of my
traders chris architect never done forex
before
after trading and fumbling about in the
past
uh he came to me and 92
in five months i'm not saying everyone
can do that but that's one of our
most solid results and he's meticulous
in his detail
we've had other people done like 20 in
five months others have done 53 in 12
months so like it varies it's down to
your personality
or your risk profile whatever so i'm
actually more proud nowadays of the kind
of results i create in others
because i'm actively bringing in really
high level clients that become traders
whether they've got businesses
beforehand
um and or or their property owners you
know they're not even business owners
they're just
their own property so that that's the
kind of people i love
i also do business coaching but that's a
whole different thing those people make
a lot of money too
yeah what what kind of um people would
you say i'm not cut out for this like
are there some people where you're just
like you know what this is really not
for you continue doing what you're doing
yeah 100 in fact my policy at fortune
academy and i teach all my teammates is
to say
no as soon as we have the red light like
come up
a red flag in the conversation we
interview anyone who comes on our top
level
so their red lights are people who
haven't okay
if you're 21 and you've never worked a
[ __ ] day in your life
i am pissed off like there are 21 year
olds that come to me and say i want to
be really wealthy
i'm like why because i just want to help
my parents i'm like okay you're 21 have
you even have you got a job they're like
no i've tried everywhere i've got one
[ __ ] 16 till 21 haven't got any
money to pay for your family i don't
believe you
so those kind of people i don't believe
when they say i want to help my parents
you've had five [ __ ] years to do
something
and you've done [ __ ] all i don't believe
you like go back get a job
sainsbury's tescos whatever like there
are jobs deliveroo
then come back to me i hate the young
mindset and their work ethic is really
[ __ ]
um those the the people i other people
i'm saying no to
um i guess we've had some people
who constantly complain i don't know i
think that's my biggest no the young
people who
live at their paris house still and
pretend like they want to do amazing
things but i haven't got a job
they're my biggest mo so and they'll
probably hate you for saying that but
then
in a few years they'll realize you're
absolutely correct oh yeah
i'm sure like damn if you do down if you
don't and and you as a trainer as well
might be
related to that because because if you
take someone on board who's young
and broke who's got a broke mindset
who's never worked a job but they want
to get really rich
if you say to them no you can't because
you're young and broke and you've got
the wrong mindset go work in tesco and
come back to me in two years
then you then they'll say you're
discriminating against them because they
haven't got a job and then if you take
them they're going to fail and then
they're going to blame you that they
failed so it's like
it's best i'd rather than just say
samuel was an [ __ ] and
he didn't he didn't have me on his
training i'd probably rather that
than than them just be a loser and bring
my stacks down
yeah yeah absolutely and then the other
person i just uh
was thinking of exactly that i mean if
they haven't um
i forgot the other criteria but i'll
come back to me but there are some
big publications i've noticed as well
you've been on some pretty big um
i've seen you in some big magazines and
in articles and things
talk to me a little bit about some of
that oh okay so i've had good and bad so
like the good
stuff is just you know like that i've
had well me i've got one coming out soon
the forbes
uh because i i i'm a peak performance
coach for credit suisse
so that's like the bank and the bankers
and the head of credit suisse
pays me to coach their team because they
know that i'm cutthro
they're like yeah she makes people fix
their mindset they make more money as a
result so
a team of 12 traders for example i got
them to one billion mark
uh in their trading so that was pretty
good yeah
yeah and it came down to the simple
stuff i mean i'm sure if i put you in
front of them
you would also help them the same way
you'd be surprised how many people in a
95 which is what bankers are 95
they are thinking so like an employee
and not like an entrepreneur
and making them have that shift of like
on getting their [ __ ] together basically
that's all it takes for them to suddenly
start making more money which i love and
i found that really easy to do i think
i've just
always had that um and then the other
part so i've had publications where
gosh i don't even keep a tab on you know
what i don't get excited by publications
because i feel like
if they make you they can also break you
etc so i don't give a [ __ ] really i've
been on front pages of
monaco uh luxury magazines where uh that
was a big one for me because they
actually asked me to be on the cover and
i was like
wow that's nice everyone in there is a
[ __ ] billionaire like the people who
read that stuff that's why i did it
because i i wanted to get into that
billionaire network because what i'm
doing and i've moved to south of france
now
and monaco is that i just want to hang
around with these people because my
network and what i'm doing with my
company acquisitions is that
that's what's my next goal like to take
companies public
um those are the kind of people i need
to be around so just like getting
property i had my
mentors and i was always around the
great you know
the well the mindset now i'm around
these um
so those are the kind of publications i
guess i'm aware of then you get the ones
that are like okay
just blog sites and whatever i find that
that's just commonplace in fun
something like financial trading and
education you're gonna get tainted with
a lot of red paint
okay you're you're a scam because i
don't even know what most of them
actually i'll be very honest most of
them trying to extort you for money they
if you ring them up and we've had my
team ring up the the uh
the people that have blocked for us they
actually say yeah if that's not right
we're so sorry but it's going to cost
you this much because they know they're
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they can just do
that we live in a world where google
ranks negative over positive so
[ __ ] anyone can write something and i
just don't give a [ __ ] anymore i suppose
but
and the other thing that they say and i
guess there is a little bit of truth in
that is
that i don't put many assets in my name
but i teach this in my wealth protection
sort of training that i give because i
learned being really naive i was very
like straightforward when i grew up like
in my 20s
i wanted everything my name like all
these houses they're mine like yeah yeah
it feels good
but then i learned the hard way and
another reason why i left property
there are so many drug dealers in
property it was me buying the houses and
the [ __ ] drug dealers buying houses
that was how we knew each other because
he was buying one street and i was
buying the other street like they are
commonplace in coventry like the guys
who are buying big property cash or like
buying
a whole fleet of houses are we the drug
dealers
or they were like me doing back-to-back
talk shoes or something
so i came across a lot of that and then
i became a target
another thing a bit of an advice for a
young females if anyone's watching
is if you're young and you're loud and
flashy i had a chrome aston martin like
i was taking the piss a little bit i was
a bit naive
typical young money um loud
new money and i got attempted extortion
by people in that area so that was when
the police got involved and i got um
i had like a police escort of three
vehicles take me to my house i had to
move my house
i was pretty naive put it that way i had
everything on my name
everyone knew where i lived my cars were
super flashy all had these private
plates on that were like over the top
like everyone knew me even if they
didn't know me personally they knew of
me it was quite like
dumb i would say and that was my biggest
lesson when it comes to being wealthy
there is a point where you can be okay
wealthy and it's
not no one's going to care but when you
start showing you've got loads of wealth
and you're female and i was single at
the time you become a super target
like i got people i got literally people
putting notes in my door
in my house through the gate whatever
saying if you don't give us 50k we'll
come and
uh we'll find you or this and it was
just stupid and so i had to take things
off my name
then your my best friend tried to sue me
because we were in a property deal
together um i'm obviously it's my house
it was my name
and um he kept all the rents and then he
took some money from a loan shop
it's crazy [ __ ] that happens in property
you know and he gets in trouble
with the loan shot guys because he
couldn't afford his debts so he sends
them to me he's like oh she's got the
money i'm like [ __ ] sake and then
that's the thing is that hither you're
right and more money just create more
problems
there is truth in that and you're always
going to have problems it's a different
type of problem and we're not taught
how to being well known and how to
handle being very wealthy
but i think the thing is that's why so
many wealthy people
just hide away that's what i mean i
thought this i remember thinking
you know beginning of this year when i
was getting loads and loads of
nonsense being said by the media and
online and i just thought
is it really worth it like i don't need
to do this i could
but then i remembered hold on
when i first started in business i
always i always vowed and knew that i
was going to be open i was going to
share i was going to teach so i think
it's
i think what you're doing is smart
you've continued to teach you continue
to put yourself back
but just not in a flashy way i
deliberately wear cheap t-shirts
i don't have bling bling i have no
jewelry you know
i i keep it real real basic i don't keep
any
fancy stuff in my house if someone
robbed me they'd be very disappointed
they just have a whole bunch of next
t-shirts
um you know but then but then i do have
wealth and take nice holidays and live a
very
good life and have everything that i
want and i think it's just about being
kind of as well when you become very
very successful very young like you were
25 same as me
i think i think you know you're gonna
have some serious lessons and
um it matures you a bit and you know
you've got to kind of uh
you do mature a bit through it so you're
probably a different person that's what
you were 10 years old
yeah 100 i mean i did martial arts for
17 years i was pretty tough anyway
mentally i don't know about physical
physically it was tough too
but i mean the point is you can still be
flashy and whatever i
i think now but i just have no assets on
my name and that's legally allowed i
mean
i learned this from billionaires i
didn't get this information from
accounters
and people like that they are not
wealthy enough to know what to do so
when i've learned i asked the
billionaire guys like what are you doing
i use the same
sometimes in events i don't you know i
know you do events as well in
um you know physical events i had to use
security and i use the same guy that
looks after roman abramovic you know
it's stupid stuff like that but it's so
needed because that's peace of mind
knowing that
okay like i know i've been a target so
[ __ ] it i just put the things in place
that will make me not a target
uh now i can live my life happily so i'm
very careful
but i teach people now i actually teach
this stuff through my
business coaching program because i'm
like i want to make you guys filthy rich
i've got one of my students making 100k
a month after 18 months with me
and she started off at 20. uh you know
that's a big growth in 18 months now
she's she's aiming for 200
but for someone like her i teach her how
to protect her money
from divorce from bankruptcy you know
just imagine all your hard work goes to
pot because i don't know either your
partner
screws you over or something like that
that's another issue people deal with
and i
i want them to i don't only just want
them to make money i want to help them
protect their money legally
um and that's what i've done and i teach
exactly that so i'm trying to be really
transparent
uh normal that layman will get really
pissed off and think
you know i'm not nine to five person
will think there's got to be something
shady there's no companies in her name
but that's
what people will do when they're super
wealthy you know i mean
i i take people at face value anyway i'm
not i
you know what i mean some people are
trying to and i think dude delicious is
important but for me i'll just listen to
someone and if i can get good value from
it then i'll apply it if i can't i won't
apply it i don't get too hung up on
trying to
figure out digging delve into people's
businesses and stuff
for me i hear what you're saying i can
hear what you're saying is good and
makes sense so i'll just
chew the meat and if there's bones or
spit them out and then i'll get on with
my own life
yeah yeah everyone's be a student of
many but
but a blind follower of none that's the
thing i think sometimes people um
you know are looking for who shall i
blindly just follow who is who's
the guru that i can just no just just be
a student of many people and just
pull what you can from different people
no one's perfect everyone's human um
what's your strongest reason why why why
are you really doing this like what's
the
what gets you up in the morning and what
pulls you towards you know
continuing i love that question i guess
it all happened in 2008 when i had a bit
of that soul-searching time and i
thought well what the hell is life you
know like it's clearly money doesn't do
it for
just me like making money just for me
felt really boring like i thought well
how much more do i need
i'm not a very high maintenance person i
don't spend too much and stuff like that
so
if you just do stuff for you and family
at a certain point you've done enough
you know you feel like yeah everyone's
cool everyone's happy they've got enough
money
but then you need some constant growth
and i actually used to
um have a lot of life coaching and um i
had a question
and asked to me like what happened
what's the legacy you want to leave
and i feel like you can't take the money
with you when you die no one can
you know but you can only i look at
historical people i've got books here
about you know
all the amazing speeches from the world
and you've got
martin luther king you've got nelson
mandela now i used to look at all these
amazing people
um leaders of the past and no one
actually cares about the money they care
about what
meaning they gave or what legacy they
left
and i guess fortune academy is that for
me it's a legacy builder uh for me
that's what
i so all the i don't even focus on the
negatives i mean there's always going to
happen but
i love my community i've got at fortune
academy we call it the fortune family
and
it's so amazing it's so like uh you know
i love helping people so that's
something that
money can't buy in the long run like
that the effect
so even if they're with you for an acute
period of time and you've helped them
but forever their life has changed
because of what you set that's what i
want to do and that's
really the only reason i love doing the
fortune academy so i don't think i'm
ever going to stop that
well that's that's awesome here that
what's if someone was thinking like
i'm interested in learning about forex i
want to do that alongside property or
instead of property or
they wanted to kind of get the crux of
it like what do you like
okay i have um something called the
property investors crash course and
that's
that's kind of like look that's the
foundational thing come through that
and by the end of that program you're
gonna know if properties for you or not
you can have all the basics and then
there are opportunities for some people
to want to do further training if they
want
or they cannot like do you have an
equivalent for that but for forex where
people can kind of
get a training and understanding of what
forex is
that they can go through i don't know
like what what's your kind of what's
your sort of how do you help people in
on that front
yeah i love it only this year uh at the
beginning of this year uh great timing
because of covert uh we started doing an
online course for
uh financial trading so i have three
tiers of
training so i always think how it what's
the easiest way to gain trust in this
industry so like the most
badly like most people fail because they
don't know what they're doing like i
said they they don't understand risk
management so i wanted to give them the
best solid
crash course i guess yeah you can put it
it's called fast strike forex and that's
where i get everyone to start it's got a
30-day money-back guarantee like we're
so
solid on that we just know you will love
this when you try it like i know
that there is no way you can't make
money if you follow the steps it's
it's black and white so we've got that
and that's like you know
i even say in there like this is not the
end this is like the beginning if you
guys like this it's a day trading
strategy so they can make money every
day
or in one day they'll see this thing
work that's how powerful it is and it's
so much easier
what do you mean by works in one day you
mean they'll actually have to make money
yeah yeah so they can put money in one
day one day
in one hour of implementing this thing
hang on hang on so in one day
they'll actually be able to make money
and there's a 30-day
money-back guarantee yes if they
that's good that's that's that's that's
impressive stuff i i mean i'm gonna i'm
gonna have to sign up and see if
i would well i would 100 put that
challenge to you
i am that confident that i if i if you
follow that system and i know you would
read and follow it or there's videos
there's like everything's like lifetime
access to the course like it doesn't
disappear you've got to
get all the do you get like everything
all the platform you need to do your
trades
yeah all that stuff everything so the
free software we're not broker so i
don't get involved i teach you guys how
to pick a broker
we don't manage people's money so we
make a very clear disclaimer that we're
not
there's a lot of people that impersonate
me and fortune academy and they take
people's money and manage it
bad stuff so i make it very clear look
you guys are in control it's your money
it's in your account
never give it to anyone else to manage
okay so that's something i'm very clear
about in financial trading
so yeah follow this step is eight hours
crash course you follow it
as soon as you go live you can make
money in one day
like i would be very surprised if people
don't like if they that system i see
how much money do you need to put into
the system how much money you need to
start
that i mean that is nothing to do with
me because it's actually down to the
broker i know brokers allow 100 pounds
100
whatever upwards maybe sometimes 200 but
it's not much but you know it's not
going to be a life-changing amount but
i'm just saying to start up it's
dead easy yeah you you but the thing is
though you only have to make a pound and
once you've
once you've seen it working it's been a
case of rock how can i scale this how
can i
throw this and i think that's the thing
like most people don't make any money
you know
oh i'm dabbling in i'm doubling in this
and hang on how much money have you
actually made oh no
but once you've done it once you've seen
it work that's why i said give your
property get one property see the money
coming in and then and then you can
start scaling it so
okay so 30 30 i'll put a link by the way
i'll put a link in the um
on the youtube description to this and
and and honestly
i i i'm tempted to even try it out so so
so it's um 30-day money-back guarantee
like a fast track to forex yeah they're
not happy
with your training they can what are the
big strings to that like how does that
work
yeah the refund policy is very strict so
it's very black and white it's fair it's
saying look don't mix up any other
trading [ __ ] that you've done in the
past in my system like keep it my system
for example if you were teaching someone
how to do property and then they mixed
up some other weird random strategy and
they were like oh if i mentioned my
return on investment it was [ __ ] because
they did some other
bad stuff whereas if they follow just
your stuff they're gonna make money so
that's the same thing with me
follow just my strategy i will see you
make money show me proof because it's so
easy to show proof you can just download
the history of the trading
and that's it um and if you don't make
any profits
in that in that time i will give your
money back and how much
how much this is the big uh the big
finale how much
sometimes sometimes we have offers i
think the offer we're gonna give on your
link
um it could be four nine seven i believe
for the like for the webinar link so
we're gonna actually give you free info
we don't even want you guys to
just buy without knowing what you get we
want you to get an idea of what we're
doing
if it works for you what i'm looking for
for some people it'll be like
okay i want to get rich quick and they
won't go for it because i really kill
off get rich quick in my
intro basically so if you guys have got
the right mindset this is going to work
it works for anyone 100 but you just
have to have a bit of discipline so you
can get money quick but just not get
rich quick
yes you can make cons when i say get
rich quick and i'm sure you'd agree
you can't you know replace your income
with forex in one day unless you've got
at least 100k to put in your account you
know then
most people don't so i'm thinking in a
beginner's mindset where they just got a
few hundred
then yeah you have to take it in steps
uh but you can certainly make
i've got my traders are replacing their
bills
now they're on the they're taking the
money from me and so they're going to
replace their monthly income so yeah
we've had transitions massively of
yeah so you're south of france so it's
all virtual training it's all
pre-recorded videos that go through
their own pace
it's 497 but before you take a penny you
want to put them on a webinar first so
they can get to
really explore what it is do that if
they do want to register it's 497
they're going to go through it and then
if they've done everything and it's not
worked out and it's terrible they can
get their money back within 30 days
yeah absolutely that sounds fair that
sounds really fair
so awesome so okay cool well i'll put a
link in the video
what were your final pieces of advice to
someone watching this that just wants to
be successful it just wants to be able
to say
everything here the man touches seems to
turn to gold everything samuel leaves
touches instead of god
how can i get that success back to like
what would you advise what would you say
always welcome yourself eighty percent
of the time like literally read read
read learn learn learn never stop
learning and learn about what makes your
mind
tick i understand what makes you do the
bad stuff in life i
limitations about money about people
stuff that's holding you back
that is probably the most important
things to work on
once you've broken through those
barriers you're honestly you're a
limitless person i feel like that is so
achievable
you can put you can't touch anything and
it turns to gold because you've worked
on yourself you've done the work
and i believe everyone who has got to
that point they love the learning
process and they never stop
so that would be my advice that's great
well listen i really appreciate you
coming on i really appreciate your time
i hope you get some
great people um registering onto your
webinar and checking that out
and listen if you do register to the
webinar if you listen to this and you
check it out
please message me samuel leaves tell me
how you got on i'm really interested
because i love to see people winning
if that's in property or if that's some
business or if that's in something else
so
heather thank you so much for your time
i appreciate it i appreciate you
and um maybe next time we'll do it in
person but it's difficult we've covered
and you being in the south of france me
being in england
but uh i really appreciate you coming on
now i appreciate it you would love it
here and
you know you fly out here one and a half
hours two hours it's worth the trip i
gotta see in front of me mountains there
i think in person should be out here
next time who knows oh maybe maybe i'll
come out
thanks so much so much see you soon bye